gottardo
antes de mais é que agradecer a toda a
organização preço do convite é é um
desafio pra mim
alerto já ao início só ver alguma queda
ao engasgar não se assusta é normal no
colorido de areia é mestra apresentar o
meu nome é se ela tem cura é seu design
de moda da marca susana bettencourt é so
é professor convidado a dançar domínio e
do modo até e para além disso faço um
equilíbrio e malabarismo entre mil e uma
tarefas de parcerias e trabalho estou
muito envolvida com a indústria porque
pensa que esse nosso trabalho com
designs temos cada vez mais é aumentar a
parceria é que fui convidada para falar
do tema tudo ou nada e estou muito o
problema português que nós temos relação
à falta de confiança e é e eu já fui
emigrante francesa antes viviam anos
portanto conseguia absorver um pouco do
modo a cultura destes meus desejos que
na verdade nós portugueses estamos
atrasados e hoje vocês provaram isto uma
vez mais e para além disso é termos uma
falta de confiança que demoramos muito
tempo a tomar uma decisão que outros
temas têm que falar aqui falamos muito
do tudo-ou-nada 8080 ou vai ou racha
ainda há outras que não posso falar aqui
não tem mais comentários
mas na verdade nós portugueses temos
estas próximas não acompanhar
estamos mais ligados que ela sempre é
antónio variações é para amanhã hoje já
não deu tempo
não é a minha menina que eu vou fazer
toda a manhã no dia vai vender um vulto
forma vou falar com toda a gente mas ao
mesmo tempo vou conseguir 2003 todas
chegamos ao fim do dia não deu esta
manhã novamente não é e eu sou eu
próprio sou vítima e faz parte do e pra
mim é como português que sou é e agora
falando um pouco do meu mundo e eu desde
2001 sem a minha própria marca e
exibições da moda são seis em seis meses
é nós agora fazemos o verão para daqui
um ano vocês tirem essa espécie de luta
que um ano vocês podem ir lá comprar mas
não é não é vocês vão ver bem tudo
inútil
vamos calar ficar apaixonado pelas peças
mas nós temos que responder a todos os
seguidores e é todas as pessoas
oi no próprio setembro ou em janeiro
podem ir à loja tal paulo mas não haja
né
no entanto temos uma grande concorrência
é da parte da produção em massa das
marcas shopping como estão dizendo não
me é não poder me a ela que na verdade
aparece em fio ou aparece uma droga ou
não influência e já está na loja em
muitas vezes nós porque nós podemos
fazemos nos queixamos nem cepa
eu não consigo fazer tempo e o sistema
não ajuda a vender e eu não tenho
dinheiro eu não tenho dinheiro eu não
consigo mudar o sistema não consigo dar
a volta às coisas porque não têm
capacidade financeira essa sempre foi
minha resposta é te confunde a talvez
ainda que as minhas influências inglesas
que eu pensei que possa deslizar que
enquanto pensava em estudar é muito
tempo a debater um primeiro nome próprio
que achava que ia fazer uma grande
asneira e também com outras pessoas com
quem nós vamos aconselhar das pessoas
que vivem connosco à parte a equipa
também é loucura não temos tempo não
fará bater constantemente mas eu disse
não
duas coisas que eu tenho um problema
menor
eu faço os fios espécies não tantos
filhos o que é um problema a nível de
vendas quando eu tenho interesse e
quando eu consegui captar uma conhece eu
não estou pronta para ser lida com o
mundo da moda assim dita por outro lado
estou cansada eu pensava de fazer sempre
a coleção comercial o que não a camisa
lá e achar que eu vendo não é eu
continuo sempre fazer a mesma técnica
tentando evoluir um pouquinho com essa
inflexão mas sempre num ritmo muito
lento até confundir que eu procurei
é pra fazer o que eu gosto ou é
realmente para desafiar a mim mesma
talvez daqui ninguém doida e outras com
rui baião um bocadinho mas também não
foi assim no meu bem e fui ouvir um ano
de preparação não foi logo em grande
loucura entre é baixinha expectativas
das minhas coleções para poder é melhor
para me preparar e pela primeira vez fiz
uma coleção físicas amostras e fiz logo
uma edição limitada e uma produção de
ver estas amostras viram que as pessoas
gostam tirar os números depois para
produzir outra vez se as fábricas duas
vezes né e que dessa vez tudo isso
além disso como também precisava de um
certo nervosismo e de um certo desafio
para o estado para fazer porque eu acho
que as pessoas são boas já que gostam de
fazer
e naquilo que desafia não é portanto eu
dizia a mim própria envolvem as minhas
raízes o que houve aumento gosta do
trabalho na eu gosto mas a dupla
português às minhas origens italianas
eu aprendi com a minha boca minha
vizinha eu aprendi renner vivo familiar
disse
o crochê bordado a ouro e se por -
talvez das poucas coisas que os odores
em mim eu sei que na verdade são
especiais
posso não ter mais nenhuma capacidade
mas essa facilidade de pegar numa mala
inventar o plano olha pra ler e isso
esse dom
não sei se foi um dom sempre treina
desde os cinco anos estará às vezes se
esquecem se pode não ser um dom mas como
resposta a isso desde os cinco anos como
é homem conseguir aprender e agora é
como se fosse natural e como se fosse
respirar
então aí para esse fim definitivamente a
coleção crucial
mostrei as lojas conseguia organizar as
coisas que agora vou ter um fila às oito
da noite e este fio as peças já estão à
venda
neste preciso momento além disso como
desafio não era grande o suficiente e
por que a inspiração da coleção era a
opção também criada pelo nosso tudo ou
nada 8 80
na verdade não estamos a conseguir
acompanhar as horas do dia não chega os
índices de depressão em portugal e de
ajuda diante de precisão cada vez melhor
posso dizer que 43 por cento da nossa
população
o número dos suicídios talvez porque os
outros não tenham tido a menos
incidentes indo bem
no entanto a percentagem de suicídio e
morte em portugal também aumentou
substancialmente e não existe nem apoio
não existe forma de ganhar essas
ferramentas em nível de ensino o nível
da ajuda continuada
essa experiência para minha coleção ela
chama stop e pela primeira vez também eu
achei que o tio era era pouco por ter
minhas peças levam dias a serem feitas
não é uma hora são duas horas são dias
quando elas são feitas à mão em uma
passagem de modelos uma situação atrasa
que estão à frente e ninguém vê é que o
deputado e eu disse eu quero interação
com o público e o meu desejo que a
interação com o público supostamente
agora vai aparecer num vídeo mas não dá
para ser a depois de o partilhar as
minhas redes sociais tudo tem cura
no entanto o homem em blocos top destrói
cante lá e aqui presentes na minha
apresentação
é que pela primeira vez que a mãe
público tenha coragem pra mudar a forma
nem todo até esta próxima das nossas
expressões e interagir e tirar visto por
eles estarem perto e poderem vir a
aumentar oficial trabalham
estudar em portugal foi uma das
primeiras vezes que pergunte para
apresentação dessas
foi difícil o projovem sabe como é óbvio
ao início não cria é uma interação ao
este perigo que na verdade é perigoso a
falta de segurança existe nenhuma
desculpas para isso não acontecer
no entanto e vão ver daqui a nada
a resposta foi imensa e interação foi
espetacular comportamento acima das
minhas expectativas e acho que podemos
conseguir marcar
não vi na vida das outras pessoas mas
pelo menos na minha fiz um marco que não
sinta orgulhosa de si não passo e
conseguir dar a volta
as exigências não tentando responder às
exigências dos outros mas efetivamente
criando as minhas próprias ela ganhe o
gostinho do que na verdade não se hoje
estou aqui com vocês só pensava 11 10
assim que maia tem uma apresentação de
uma parceria com a energy uma área com a
sucessão à patente de ajuda ao suicídio
é que temos uma substância é é apenas
para fundos e para ajudar essa situação
e depois às 8 horas tem muito filme e
confesso que também é muita gente disse
três dias depois novo num dia mas enfim
a 13 26 não posso tudo entender que ela
não bola mas quando dizemos a nós
próprios e quando nós fomos cada vez
mais um fio da navalha
o que eu acredito é quando conseguimos o
próprio o próximo desafio que parece que
é o paciente sempre aparece qualquer
loucura qualquer problema eu penso é só
mais um
já consegui o 3d em todas ele esperava
por 5 é que ela não podendo se fosse mas
pelo menos sei perfeitamente o que
sempre no fio da navalha e sempre impõe
a prova tem ultrapassado as minhas
próprias provas
aquilo que eu vim aqui tentar mostrar o
exemplo que eu quis dar foi efetivamente
é roupa eu não posso esquecer que temos
roupa elevados são coleções as pessoas
que eu influencio acima de tudo não
sejam os alunos em um jovem com muita
paciência a ser a minha equipa trabalha
comigo diretamente em as pessoas que
partilham a vida que leva
no entanto eu acho que se cada um de nós
conseguir influenciar um bocadinho à sua
volta
todo mundo vai ser diferente e acho que
não teremos cada vez mais deixaram é
para amanhã
eu acho que nós queremos uma coisa agora
é não dizer que te fazer logo no dia
system treino sem pensarem bem e não
digo isso mas realmente é um desejo e se
realmente queremos mudar qualquer coisa
ou simplesmente queremos ser melhores
então eu acho tem que usar quinto ano
que vem começará por dizermos intuitiva
e tem que começar por nós próprios e
acreditamos em nós
infelizmente nós em portugal entendo que
nossa democracia é efetivamente um dos
problemas no entanto suspensa amanhã
quem é deus pensa de maneira diferente
especial o objetivo são pragmáticos e
isto quanto da minha experiência em
inglaterra porque na verdade eu pensando
no objetivo nós tivemos temos aqui temos
aquela placa temos esse problema aqui e
vamos manter um problema de cada vez
mantendo os objetivos do movimento
mantendo o nosso olho naquilo que nós
queremos conquistar mas sem parar por um
caminho nem com os obstáculos é só mais
um né e era criar acima tudo estar aqui
é mais do que um trabalho mais do que a
roupa teria falado tudo ou nada é eu
acho que é preciso arriscar tur e acima
tudo nós vamos para porque quando tentei
fazer a minha pizza ou por transferência
eu achei que era uma galera e claro que
tem que sonhar que sorte que não fui a
única designer que também sentiu esta
cidade que também que inverter as coisas
de jogar o jogo de outra maneira é que
também me ajudou
foi só uma seleta tinham que não com
três ou quatro designers a pedir este
deus não tiveram forma de tentar afundar
nós
no entanto só foi possível porque alguém
tomou o primeiro passo de propor e
alguém em um primeiro passo de planear e
realmente arriscar tudo não vou dizer
que estes foi foi normal não foi esta a
apresentação nível de dex de bastidores
foi uma grande loucura desde os placares
arranjar patrocinadores arranjar
parceiros que pudessem fazer parte e
contra o sistema é difícil e as pessoas
vão efectivamente criar resistência e
aspas mesmo os próprios processos não
têm assistência mas quando acreditamos e
é marlon dentro da minha segurança como
é normal na verdade a insegurança mas
dentro da minha segurança eu tenho uma
grande dose de loucura que faz com que o
convença as outras pessoas lá e esperar
muito para passar aqui foi apenas um
pouco da minha história que não mudou o
mundo apenas aquilo que o mundo dá é
muito carinho mas é um passo para que eu
acredito que eu acho que efetivamente é
nova roupa tendo em conta o mundo em que
estamos hoje em dia tem que ficar lenta
sinal de que muitos anos efetivamente
não vamos ter o nosso campeonato não
vamos ter essa sabedoria
ninguém vai passar esse conhecimento eu
podem ocorrer mesmo esta geração eu já
sou das últimas pessoas que realmente
têm este gostinho de conhecimento e se
eu não for passado nós vamos perder as
nossas raízes e eu acho que é uma forma
de criar futuro e não há forma de criar
tudo você clicar no nome